Theo thông tin được qua chức năng Philippines, hàng nhiên người dân đã được sơ tảnh khỏi của book Vietnam từ đôn Mà Đi La,
sau khi nguy lượng may yòn phương trào, người phát tảm cho buổi trị dựa dọng tại tình Amai.
Bộ phúc lời sá hội và phát triển Đôn dịch Sia cho biết, có gần 1 năm xam gia đình đang tạm chú tại các trung tâm sơ tảm.
Chào buổi dây đặc sốt hiện anh hưởng tới nhiều cuu dân cơ và làm giám đoạn sau thông địa phương.
Để nguy lượng ở về đị trắng Philippines đã nâng mất cảnh báo lên các bà trong thẳng năm tất cả.
Hãy quyền có người dân không tiếp cận của book Vietnam trong bản kính sau khi lượng may quen miệng nguy lượng,
có quen này khi nhận các đường phùn dung nhằm nhắm, cùng nguy cơ lượng đất và giòn khi nắm.
Trong bà cán người 1 bà thẳng năm, phí bó sơ biết đang khi nhận 3-2 chạm đất nguy lượng,
hàng chăm vụ đá dây và nhiều tiên nhở giòn khi cho nắm.
H hiện tưởng phát sáng tại miệng nguy lượng của tịch quân sát bằng mắt thường,
trong khi các dụ hiệu biến sạch địa hình cho thấy hòa đồng địa chất vẫn còn tiếp s眼.